Annie Leibovitz took this photo of you
with giant I think it's a Python or I
you know what I don't like snakes enough
to even bother finding I don't know it
was a big snake you're scared of snakes
and you took this iconic photograph
which we have right here of you with
this snake and I can't believe you have
you are deathly afraid of snakes
well what did any Libra would say to you
to say I hate snakes
but I'm naked throw one on me it wasn't
even that I mean she had said that she
wanted to have this idea to photograph
me as Eve so I knew I was gonna be naked
with maybe a fig leaf somehow I forgot
about the snake right I don't know if
you've ever had to work with a snake in
that but it smelled really first of all
its smell disgusting right it was heavy
and it was curious let's just say that
the tail of the snake kept going in
places that and I wasn't going to shoot
it's like moving around and it's just
like that's crazy
nice to think about well there's were
like I mean the snake was squeezing my
shoulders and the tail was going all
kinds of places and I kept saying to
this right I might come and take it off
but finally Annie was like I think we
got it and I was like thank God I
survived so yeah it's crazy to me we've
had a lot of experience here with
animals and snakes I've never had a
snake draped over me when I was naked I
mean I'd do that in private but not on
television but yeah they're joking there
too but I'm not good I'm not fast enough
to get it so okay all right
yes just found how do you feel because
some of these photographs are so iconic
you have all these fans you did a bunch
of Playboy covers you must have the
experience of when you show up someplace
people will have your old Playboy covers
and they want you to sign them yeah and
you know sometimes it can get like it's
one thing when the magazine's just out
but you know if it's a Playboy cover and
and some let's say the guy is like 55
and wants you to sign it you ever get
creeped out by that you know only when
they're laminated that I just made sure
they you know what people come up to me
at airports and and it's always we're
like the first guy in line when you're
doing a book signing always has the
Playboy and you know they're like I hope
it's okay that I brought this and at
this point in my life I'm like bring it
on I wonder you know that was like I
look great in those pictures and I'm
happy to sign them but you know there's
there's like what I remember used to
getting them from like prisons and
things like I get a lot of stuff from
prison I tell is keep it coming
Rocko yours is in the mail hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please